during this press tour you've been
everywhere we've loved getting to see
you and the world has loved to getting
to see you did you know you broke the
internet excuse you next well on the
internet you became a meme so this is a
picture of Beyonce and now people are
saying me saving all the GQ photos of
Brad Pitt I see - my phone it's a meme
showroom 55 looks good on him Lord
Internet's like Oh Lord he's looking fly
Lord that speak for you're doing good
babe great what can you tell us about
the Lima project its objective was to
search for advanced extraterrestrial
life and the commander was he was my
father Sir
your father was experimenting with a
highly classified material that could
threaten our entire solar system we're
counting on you to find out what's
happening out there
so congratulations what a year for you
two fabulous pieces of cinema this is
such a wonderful time and such a crazy
press tour will you be done after this
for the year are you gonna relax to put
it away yes get on to other things
how does Brad Pitt relax make you some
new things just friends family get
outside make some things fishing scripts
keep making last thing it is the 25th
anniversary of interview of vampire what
does it mean to you it's crazy this year
what do you remember from that time on
set I'm flesh and blood I wasn't sure
still going to be here so I'm pretty
grateful for that there's ever a reboot
or like the next generation of that
movie like we see you well I don't think
it'd be so interesting of Tom and I
jumped in again maybe someone else yeah
yeah gratulations man good to see you
thank you so much